las celebraciones de fin de año para
2021 parecen en gran medida frustradas
por la nueva ola de coronavirus vuelos
cancelados en eeuu debido al personal
contagiado varios países de europa como
francia españa y reino unido- ven
números récord de contagios en solo un
día el regreso de la obligación de usar
mascarillas en italia un estricto
confinamiento en los países bajos
recuerdan al 2020
creo que es más que correcto y apropiado
usarlo tanto en el exterior como en el
interior aparte de las reglas que
existen es una cuestión de seguridad
para todos los ciudadanos de italia y
del mundo es correcto usarlo llevarlo
siempre y sobre todo vacunarse está bien
hacerlo
en marruecos un decreto del gobierno
mantendrá los aviones internacionales
fuera de su territorio al menos hasta
finales de enero la medida en vigor
desde hace un mes debía expirar el 31 de
diciembre en américa del sur ecuador se
ha convertido en el primer país del
mundo en imponer la vacuna obligatoria
desde los 5 años en adelante una medida
dirigida directamente al 30% de la
población que aún no está vacunada
nosotros como ciudadana ser conscientes
y venir personalmente a valorarnos bien
que no esté navegando dos años después
de que se propagara por todo el mundo el
kobe 19 ha dejado más de 5 millones de
muertos un número según la organización
mundial de la salud que se ha
subestimado en gran medida